[Music]
[Music]
hey welcome back to the genuine podcast
with our completely original theme song
that we just made up on the spot this
week's episode is brought to you by this
skin guys you know what this game is
we've talked about it okay it's just the
most efficient way to get your
information there's a newsletter all the
top news stories condense perfectly into
a bite-sized email it goes right to your
email address
every morning okay it's free doesn't
cost a thing
you just jump in and you go alright
right now go to the skim that's th es ki
mm comm slash annejulien you'll be
entered to win a $250 Visa gift card and
just subscribe to the newsletter if you
don't like it you don't have to stay
give it a shot
check it out you can destroy
conversations at work with all your
knowledge that you'll have from the skim
is a great service and it's completely
free check it out guys also me Indies
the wonderful me Indies that has been
outfitting our wonderful closets with
even more wonderful underwear for a long
long time guys there's undies and then
there's me Andes there is seriously no
comparison me Andes are three times
softer than cotton you understand it
until you feel it right now check it out
get 20% off and free shipping with their
100% satisfaction guarantee by going to
me undies that's MV you and di es hamsa
and Julian or click the link in the
description you will not be disappointed
I'm wearing them right now I will even
show you yeah you do too where are they
you've been hiding them from me no I
mean have you been wearing my songs boy
what the actual [ __ ] oh I don't blame me
the very comfortable
q what are we doing today I think Julie
just wanted to eat chicken wing
something [ __ ] oh okay
so here's the thing we are we are a lake
full of ideas collectively we are one
lake it's called idea lake go on and we
are flowing with inspiration all day and
night we don't know what to do with it
so sometimes we just have to let it
spill out into the podcast and let you
guys have a little little bit of little
bite of that little bite of that I'm
trying to do a thing oh sorry I'm trying
to bring them into the moment mm-hmm
with sensory overload
[Laughter]
[Music]
everyone here has probably heard of the
show hot ones it is a show hosted by
Sean Evans on YouTube made by first we
feast
he basically interviews celebrities over
hot wings and they get progressively
hotter as the interview goes on he's a
wonderful guy a pleasant person in a
really talented interviewer so the show
is really popular so we want to do our
own shitty version of it where we just
ate our own vegan chicken hot wings and
asked each other questions
well we already like know everything
about each other we just we wrote like
some derpy questions really think that
Julian just wanted to eat my favorite
comment is when people are like you
should go on hot ones as if it's like
you just walk in there like hey guys I'm
on hot ones oh oh that's much better
here we go there's that light we've been
looking for [ __ ] okay so what I did
and if you'd like to check out the
behind the scenes on how I made these
vegan hot wings there's a little clip of
the vlog right here we're gonna put in
and you can click on that or go see the
vlog it's on my channel now you ordered
those wings though well I made them
you'll see you'll find out in the vlog
but basically I have four sets of wings
we're each gonna have one of each mm-hmm
and they they get hotter as they go
scared what you bought
okay so I'm gonna explain no I got a
bunch of napkins here we got a bunch of
napkins okay so the first one is Frank's
Red Hot extra
we're starting off with extra huh
because you scoffed when I said we have
Frank's redhot we can do this yep well
originally you were like let's just do
hot ones cuz I was currently watching
hot ones you decided you wanted chicken
wings in the moment like a true Eritrea
nice of a brilliant Aries all we have is
like sriracha and Frank's redhot and you
were like you stopped and you stopped so
I said okay try me [ __ ]
so I ran to the grocery store and I
bought four new hot sauces okay we're
gonna start with the most rapes red hot
extra hot has me actually quaking I have
never had that in the upstate New York
and me is dying so here's the thing go
on I ordered them probably really
improperly because I didn't follow the
Scoville scale
I followed the Seoul Amitabh Ville scale
which is basically you look at the hot
sauce and you think oh that's probably
this hot and then you determine the
signs of it right then in there so
number one the most mild confirmed by me
not tasted no scientists nothing Frank's
redhot extra hot is number one that is
our starting flavor we're starting the
interview with that so they might go up
and down they might go up yeah it might
be a [ __ ] [ __ ] roller coaster I do
know that the last hot sauce is very hot
okay
the second one is more of an Asian Flair
it's a hot chili sauce with the chili
oil mixed in so you get like little
pieces of chili on it okay I actually
wanted to do a little dab like they do
on each so the first dab do you even
watch the show you think fans know they
do do a little dab of it on top of each
wing that's how it looks like that stop
don't tell me to stop I made a stone I
mean it's a beast okay this is our
wedding okay so the second one is hot
chilli Asian sauce that's like really
oily but it's like spicy like Asian
spicy then we have a Jamaican Jerk sauce
Oh delicious which is a nice different
flare actually I went out of order it
goes it goes Jamaican second and then
hot chilli third because I Chili's hot
hotter than Jimmy
Jamaican is not that hot the Jamaican
Jerk sauce is not that hot because
that's this one you taste any of these
before eating how do you think I could
develop this so Lomita Ville scale
what do you use this the Scoville scale
she's talking to my [ __ ] ear mic
running the back and the forth sauce and
the hottest one is gringo gringo Bandito
extra hot okay okay so this isn't normal
Greenville bendito this is extra or
super hot rather okay this is a Mexican
hot sauce this is the this is the last
step that's what we're doing for the
finale and then we have your um vegan
blue cheese and like hot ones were a lot
to use blue cheese weight being blue
cheese and what else be rich oh okay so
basically we're just gonna get
crack-a-lackin' on asking each other
some question what it's better to be out
of control than in control because when
you're in control what do you do you're
stuck get out of it and then you do
whatever you want control of the state
of mind all right let's do it
you first well we have to take a bite of
the wing okay here we go we Cheers
okay cuz how they do it that this is
nice so hungry
me too mmm chewing that one's like a
traditional Buffalo away and that is not
my oh no I was pretty glad mm-hmm I feel
like I thought you were dumping on mine
like excuse you I think that's like what
I want Frank's redhot to taste like yeah
it's like hot it's not only hotter than
from traditional drinks but it's better
mm-hmm cuz it has an extra heat all
right you guys question for you is what
time is it when you run out of ice cream
time to die any other answers or is that
it um time to accept the fact that
you're probably lactose intolerant
oh okay um time to throw down the map
and have it land on somewhere you don't
wanna go and then just forget you ever
threw the dardan and then don't go God
okay and then also time to go get more
ice cream all right good stuff how I do
great don't chew right in the mic it's
making me grossed out
don't do that Julian what is your
favorite thing about me mmm you mean
aside from your bought we've told that
story right
the butt story but you know what in the
picture mmm have we I don't know I don't
know why either are we gonna let expose
him I'll tell it
that's explosive expose I'm so harmless
no so I I should go get the rest of
these you don't finish these well you
can try to order I fine Julian just
relax
so the butt story is this is a wonderful
story I did something with todrick he
had an MTV show and we had he'd been
asking me to do so just I'm not trying
to chew into the mic don't move my mic
control yourself
don't control me I even I wanted to work
with todrick for a long time and love
todrick he's amazingly talented and
sweet and he had an MTV show and it
finally worked out that I was able to go
do it or whatever and so I met todrick
and he was you know amazing wonderful
and he says to me you know I have to
tell you something and I'm like okay and
I'm like started thinking of anything it
could possibly no idea
he goes you boyfriend's Julian solo
meteorite it was like yeah how did you
know that like that's funny you know do
you know him you guys know each other
and he goes well see like a month or two
ago this was a long time ago yeah this
was many years ago now like maybe three
years ago now he was like Julian had
gone to a Miranda sings show with Josh
and todrick was there as well as at the
LA show or something and he saw Julian
didn't know who he was and just saw his
butt and was like that is the most
beautiful perfect but I have ever seen
in my life and he was like I took a
picture of it cuz it was so amazing and
he shows me on his phone and he's like
I'm just so sorry I took the picture of
your friends but on my phone and I just
started dying laughing Lee yes freeze
looking great he's like for my birthday
will they give me a lap down
like I don't know you can ask him that
literally happened all that is true
mm-hmm thank you all right well what's
your other favorite thing about me
besides my button mm-hmm um you're just
a doer
you're very helpful you do so much you
know you just do stuff there are a lot
of people that don't do anything and you
just do a lot of stuff that's cool
probably bad and I like you and you're
sweet and you're probably the funniest
person that I know but I'm biased cuz
everything like literally everything
that you do makes me laugh every day
well I think that one's the show with
hot questions and even hotter questions
that was good all right it's my turn
your turn go who was the most useless
superhero or Power Ranger if you can't
think of one I don't remember the Power
Rangers by like you know individual
colors but cuz I was really young but
gambits he does nothing he does magic
like a weirdo I know I know
Jenna's in the video and she talked we
were talking about gambit and she failed
to mention that he uses kinetic energy
to move the guy does magic okay he's the
lame superhero that was the point okay
so if you want to be a Marvel or x-men
purist in the comments go for it but he
sucks as a superhero he's no one's
favorite and we are big Tim Riggins fans
so even us who love Taylor Kitsch are
willing to say that the character he
played is bad he's got to be bad it's
pretty useless right yeah he's he's a
magician that's looking for a group of
friends yeah I think yeah I think cam
it's pretty bad yeah all right one for
me and then we'll move on post needs or
Twitter if you had to choose one and why
mmm-hmm if you had to get rid of one app
forever which one would you get rather
suppose me get rid of Twitter yeah
that's a realized answer by the way and
Instagram and then you know get like my
news other places that's how that's an
honest [ __ ] answer because you are on
Twitter all the time yeah and like when
it comes down to it post makes matters
it does I didn't that's always an
involuntary that was an involuntary burp
okay okay okay so this is the Jamaican
Jerk sauce made by pick opee
pick a pepper pick a Peppa Pig Peppa why
don't you just make up a name no it's
pick a pepper I just I agree here Cheers
this is not gonna be super sorry lips
are still burning from the frames we
started out like on level 9 yeah this
one's hollow right mm-hmm it's good
mm-hmm we should start without mm-hmm
sorry what what I do all right your
question for me read a little bit about
the sauce as you're chewing because this
is a pic of pepper sauce product of the
pic of pepper company LCD Shooters Hill
Jamaica it's really sweet it's good it's
a sweet sauce I like Jamaican jerk
chicken
yeah this this has raisins in it so it's
like it's you know it's not a hot sauce
but it is like a it's a chicken sauce
you remember ChaCha's chicken and jam on
top I was literally just gonna bring
that up Jim I miss that so much
there's no good like being in Jamaican
food really you have to make it yeah
back in the day so if you guys remember
the vlog Jenna put up called adventure
day remember staying at a hotel
adventure vlog adventure blog it was
like five four or five years ago we were
staying in a hotel cuz your house is
getting fumigated mm-hmm and the hotel
was like ready prostitute from cha-cha
chicken which already was one of our
like G
spots that we hit sometimes who's Jim
Rock Jamaican chicken place specializes
in like chicken and that place was so
[ __ ] we even talked about in the blog
yeah I like with chicken with SATA rice
and beans with the SATA check in this at
a recipe
yeah this brings me back to that so good
there really is no good vegan chicken
spot like specializes in like chicken no
fried chicken but they rotate it out
seasonally yeah they changed everything
all time
yeah all right do your best impression
of keke palmer at the shorty awards all
looking good fun she was wonderful but
go hey what's up y'all keke palmer hi
mom
welcome to the shorty wars i'm on
twitter follow me at keke palmer the
next artist he's not keke palmer
I'm keke palmer no she was the life was
a good question if dogs didn't exist
what animal would you surround yourself
with like we do dogs
like on the level of dogs not I know you
want every animal but like I mean I
don't even have a one answer for that I
feel like I could be surrounded by any
type of animal and I would be happy
mm-hmm as long as there's a bunch of
them yeah like I'd be happy about
surrounded by goats I'd be happy if I
was riding by horses even though I'm I'm
not an equestrian whatever you call
those people thank you talking Equestria
I don't know how to like take care of a
horse cuz I've never done that but like
I would love to learn if I if that was
my reality and I just had this table
full of horses like I could do some
sheep I could do some cats I could do
rats
I could do mice I can do anything what
would you cuddle with a night mmm if
there were no dogs yes maybe a kitty cat
I don't really like a kitty it's pretty
easy answer I like yeah but look I had a
ferret I love ferrets cage that right I
would get a pot-bellied pig like I don't
care a pig I'm dumb yeah egg would be
fun like adorable and they're so smart I
would love to have one but it's
unrealistic for me maybe I don't know
when we going yeah whoops yeah first
things first let's get a Husson and get
a pig no problem all right Pig good
bacon cat all right one more question
yeah one more question
um there's an earthquake the ceiling is
fallen in but you know you gonna be
hungry what food
item you grabbing out of the house out
of the house so it's something we like
regularly stop yeah I would probably
it's a good question I would get my jug
of orange juice in the fridge gross okay
why why is that gross it's nature's most
wonderful pulpy vitamin C juice okay I
would grab my jog of I'd probably grab I
feel like I keep like frozen bagels or
bread in the freezer at any time grab
the whole bag mm-hmm and how many items
do I get mmm couple I would get I would
get rice I would get a whole bag of like
a family-sized bag of sushi rice which
we have yep okay literally yeah we have
that yeah and then I would figure out a
way cook it and nooch are getting used
yes what would you get probably just the
jar of peanut butter that's way more
sensible you're gonna be chewing on
grains of rice hard I had a similar
question so I'm gonna do that right now
if there was an apocalypse mm-hmm
similar situation earthquake whatever
and you had to stock up on your favorite
beauty products which Oh three beauty
products would you choose everybody okay
okay there's a bar of soap that I really
enjoy it's by a company called swell
skin which I saw on one of those stupid
reality TV shows yes like knock off
Shark Tank comes on like Bravo I think
but it's not even know so much about
that it's the ingredient that's in it
that I fell in love with the sea
buckthorn oil so have like a bar of soap
that has sea buckthorn oil in it which
is really nice and tough my skin with a
lot of stuff I would take a bar of that
I would take my rose water spray beach
you know I'm about that which I tried it
a different brand recently you know it
was it's just as good it's just
greedy incident the rose wine love it
amazing cannot live without it and I
would take benefit they're real mascara
so I could not look dead all the time
alright that's good
those are my three beauty I don't know
what I would pick a so great and I
mascara Beach and I'm ready to go you
could do a lot with those three extra
yeah it you can stay clean you could
stay fresh with the rosewater and your
eye lashes would stay on path luck yeah
like flock on flock alright your turn
are we eating another wing yeah let's do
it let's let's we're on number three now
three out of four this is the hot chili
sauce that chili yeah this one is gonna
be spicy so here we go we got add a bit
no we don't there we go
sure so it's gonna how do you know
what's gonna be spicy don't wipe my eye
you're gonna wipe it into my eye it
would be okay because it would still
taste good
I'm touching hot hot stuff I guess your
vision got really hot what that's not
spicy at all it is no it's not okay well
my order was a little wrong but this is
really yummy and we're gonna do a little
extra over the no it's hella yummy no no
I don't want you to just dump out [ __ ]
on the table no too late cuz it's on the
table now just like all this red chilly
stuff yeah you got it to make the choice
yeah yeah yeah it's not spicy oh please
and Chili's honor eating the Chili's
this what's that
what are these square things I don't
know it's all being a trick though what
was that
that's not a hot sauce at all it's like
crunchy what's in there is that vegan
that's vegan I checked all right this
isn't spicy I'm sure
I tried okay there's my first hot ones
welcome to mild ones bland food they can
even Melander conversation that's good
sorry you got a question for me mm-hmm
yeah hold on let me turn my phone on and
not splash this hot [ __ ] in my face
mmm okay mm-hmm tell us why you started
using the phrase sick [ __ ] [ __ ] you
know I got it I started using the phrase
sick [ __ ] because what he says it like
every night we'll meet again that
question is a sick [ __ ] I'm exposing
you okay
we were driving to organ visit Jenna's
family for Christmas and so we were
listen to Shane and friends podcast as
we normally do one on long drives and
Shane had jeffree star on one of his
episodes and I knew little to nothing
about Geoffrey start prior so listening
to the podcast really was intriguing to
me because he's like a kind of a
brilliant businessman and he's done a
lot in the beauty world like
business-wise he's kind of created this
Empire he's a people have very strong
opinions I do know he's controversial
I'm not I'm not discounting any of that
I'm just kind of from the business side
of things just listening to and and I
don't I like literally watched none of
his YouTube video so I don't really you
know it's not from the one we're going
to talk about but um oh yeah so I don't
I can't speak to the stuff that you know
may be what is caused him to be viewed
as controversial or whatever but I do
know that it was just intriguing I'm not
like I didn't fall in love with it I
just you know I was like interesting I
was interested in him in his story so
then we watched one of those edit videos
like by shook was where he was like
someone annoying someone for two minutes
trait you know that wasn't it but it was
it was uh what was the video it was when
I try to blink makeup tutorial by oh
you're right it was we did
I followed in Tana mojo tutorial that's
right and he's Jeffrey started sitting
there watching it the whole time [ __ ]
yeah so he's he's basically like
[ __ ] on her ass all the time hot ok
you already said that it's a snap did
you want to prepare a whole hot ones
that's what I thought anyway you called
her a sick [ __ ] just made me laugh
really hard so I've been using that was
pretty simple can I do some suffice them
up like wow you cop because it was so
spicy as you were complaining no just
like when I my throat weird object cough
on me
alright everyone I have my next question
ready okay um what is your favorite pair
of me undies me undies the underwear
that's three times softer than cotton
and can be shipped right to your door
with new designs each micro modal fabric
and socks and bra that's as well if that
floats your boat mm-hmm you've never
felt me and is because you don't own
them but if you if you buy now you will
own them and you will never go back to
normal underwear again like me my whole
drawer is filled with Oh me me undies
and I'm not talking about my underwear
drawer I'm talking about my kitchen
drawer I've got that many me undies that
the silverware drawer in my kitchen is
literally overflowing with me undies no
it's not it could be you never know but
for real guys me Andes is changed the
game of underwear it's like being naked
but better literally three times softer
than cotton they did that they did the
math on that okay if you were confused
at why there's all this hype around the
underwear give it a shot go to me and
he's not calm slash annejulien
20% off free shipping and if you hate
him you send them back you get your
money back which you won't you probably
won't hate them but it's worth giving a
shot because it's like one of those
things that you buy it once you're like
okay I've been doing this wrong sort of
like we bought like really good olive
oil
recently and we're like what the [ __ ]
we've been buying this cheap olive oil
it's just like changes the game for you
when you try something like
the next level up in that category so
for us me and ease is that thing and for
you it can be to go to me on these calm
/ Jen and Julian
20% of your first pair and free shipping
guys it shipped right to your door you
don't gotta go shop for it in the store
like a troglodyte okay and it's a
limited time offer so you gotta get on
it soon also guys this skin it is a
newsletter with all the top news stories
compiled perfectly organized simplified
for you in your email inbox every
morning guys the skin literally takes
all of the important things out of the
nonsense of what's on the internet every
day compiles it so you can read it it's
bite-sized it's like a little fun size
Snickers bar and you just consume it in
the morning it's free okay while you
brushing your teeth while you're doing
your business while you're taking a
shower with your waterproof phone case
if you have that or you just living on
the edge or if you eat your cereal or
oatmeal in the morning you want to read
something it's a great way to just get
the facts of what's going on in the
world you can be educated you can be
informed it is a really cool service
especially in this day and age when
there's like clouded information
everywhere you look online this cuts
through all the nonsense so check it out
guys go to the skin comm slash
annejulien you will also be entered to
win a $250 Visa gift card which you can
buy anything you want even Mia nice or
something else but check it out it is
free newsletter click the link in our
description to get started thank you
sponsors they appreciate you supporting
our show all right I think it is your
turn now
I gotta finish this wing I ate a lot of
that and if you eat a lot of it does it
get spicy eventually I'm not really all
right
are you moving on to this last spicy
wing mm-hmm that you says is hot all
right Julian mm-hmm would you rather be
standing in the middle of the crowd at
Coachella or on a Disney cruise ship
that's a lot deal with it it's the
hottest one we haven't had any spice
this whole time
[ __ ] Coachella or a cruise ship yeah how
long is the cruise I'm dumping some of
this off why are we cheersing yeah all
right green go bendito hottest waiting
here we go mmm like a week a week long
cruise or a weekend at Coachella not
like it comes in late like dipping as
you put in that you dumped it well I'm
trying to give us some heat and trying
to give us big content dip it in one
more sauce like action action I taste
the action yeah my tongues not like numb
I would say a cruise ship because at
least I could just go to like a
semi-normal bar and just get hammered
cuz I know they have bars on cruise
ships
I feel like go tell her we just drive me
insane yeah and like I would go to katoa
but I would never stand in the middle of
a [ __ ] crowd never mmm willingly
right I would I would kind of navigate
more calculated and not just end up in a
mosh pit or a crowd I just that's my
time Eric yeah yeah this one's spicy
which Spice Girl and why mmm
Geri Halliwell ginger spice loved her me
too
I loved her I thought she was so
beautiful when I was a little girl I
liked baby spice like Scary Spice like
posh I like sporty but ginger was like
my favorite mm-hmm that's good right
yeah oh that she was my favorite too and
I don't even remember a lot as festive
as you remember how much I liked her
there's only a lot about the Spice Girls
I don't remember a lot of the tito's
matter cuz I watch under my tongue it's
a late spice Antonio fast now them
thought that was like good a layer below
spice
oh it's starting to burn my tongue on a
surface spice it gets you later
my goal is gotta keep answering
questions Oh
ask me one more Oh
if a quilt has no quilting on it is it a
quilt no no it's a painting or it's
another art piece but a quilt is a very
specific medium like I think it's like a
comforter or like a blanket like there
has to be quilting on it in order for it
to be a koala when someone calls it a
quilt but it's clearly a blanket or a
comforter oh yeah no no we're not
calling things quote that hasn't been
like spent time on like that yes what is
your ideal pub G loadout armor and all
mm grips everything obviously level
through a year I don't my mine um m4
suppressed tax off stack shock Bert grid
I like the verb what's so strange hollow
quick-draw yeah and then I would say
like a suppressed k98 I really like or
suppressed SKS mini can [ __ ] itself at
this point okay haven't really focused a
lot of drop weapons I like the grows up
I like the ones that are trying
yeah um I'm to four yeah alright like I
mean I [ __ ] with them but mm-hmm
I just don't trust myself enough with
like that 20 bullets or whatever well
that's only the women that's now them
too for you can use 762 so but you okay
so an interesting point and I want to
talk about this you said you're done
with the mini which I've been done with
the mini and a lot of people have done
with the mini for a while but they've
recently announced that they're doing a
whole overhaul with rebalancing the
weapons and included in that is banning
level 3 helmets off loot spawn tables
which means you're not gonna find them
in in the world you can only get them
from drops what that means is a lot of
things right it's also a nerf to the arm
right because the arms big thing was
that a kid knock and take it could take
off your helmet and knock you in one
shot with a level 3 which no other
weapon in the game can do even an m24 it
doesn't knock you with a level 3
so it's nursing the arm indirectly it's
buffing the mini right now because the
mini against like a level 3 helmet yeah
it doesn't doesn't work I'm down but the
biggest buff to the mini is what they're
gonna do to the a ours is that I pretty
sure they're gonna take 8 times off of a
ours that's fine so eight times so that
means the mini now all value over say
the m4 before yeah alright just thought
it I don't really throw any times on an
AR that's not my job
I don't either but it is it is what a
lot of people do a lot of people don't
mm force like Kenzi I know they do but
that's not my gym yeah all right
do I know my I do load up yes okay scar
silver-plated
red dot extending quick-draw angled grip
and compensator with an a Wham extended
quick-draw suppressor cheek pad eight
times
sucks Lee elbow three everything um I
also like to add to my idea loadout ten
frag grenades seven smoke grenades yeah
yeah yeah - adrenaline syringes meaning
I hit two drops one Molotov my idea
loadout is 40 rounds of Magnum meaning
our stole just my mouth is still Bert
my mouth is cut on the inside yeah if I
could spice to cut feeling it speaking
of cut guys get this new cut of t-shirt
at our new March launching today it is
the like only we've only really have a
couple shirts we've ever launched but
this one is actually we've spent time on
this and designing it it comes in this
generous even wearing one right now I'm
wearing the camel one show the other
side look at that
put your mics in the way there we go
guys these are our new dink strips these
are official dink merch Jenna Julian
March which we literally never have I
don't know at the time of recording this
like what the link is but go to our
twitter at Jenna Julianne and we will be
tweeting out the link on Monday
we're not gonna sell out we're gonna
have a period where you can order the
shirts and then however many are ordered
that's how many we print tweeting me
that they're worried that they're gonna
sell out we're not doing the it's
and yeah it's done get your size
nutrition and it's done with design by
humans which I believe not confirmed but
I believe it's five dollars shipping
worldwide which is great because a lot
of you guys are not in the US so you'll
be able to cop them Rob do you have one
more yeah what did you
what's the Scoville level of that
where's your [ __ ] marry kill Anne
Hathaway Julia Roberts and Sandra
Bullock no yep you got it um Green go
ante to six out of ten heat flavor nine
out of ten when we go to their website
maybe they have it on their website why
don't you just answer the question oh
sorry I don't know who I don't know the
difference so [ __ ] Julia Roberts Mary
Sandra Bullock killing Hathaway oh good
yeah be with those answers I don't know
what they mean cuz I like barely have an
idea the difference put do you want
another question yeah sure if he art was
if the earth was flat would you try to
fall off yeah dude yeah
no we try to lie clean at the end of it
and just peek on the other side mmm but
not Falls yeah yeah like pubs you and
you glitch none of the map looks like
okay my question to you is growing up
did you have a favorite age or month
what no never mind I'm not gonna take
that one back if you had to do jujitsu
if you had to my last question was about
jujitsu too oh [ __ ] okay perfect
if you had to do jujitsu ah you know you
don't like it but if you had to it's not
the sport for me explain and describe
your custom key and what it looks like
please okay okay
segi mm-hmm okay let me get my vision
I'm excited for this scramble you
listening first of all it would be plaid
like red plaid yeah
but like the fashion kind whatever the
one they call that you know they're like
when's tafani where's yeah okay yeah so
then um the pants right so they would be
cut out on the side but they would be
laced up together oh girl oh so then
there'd be glitter elbow pads the caller
would be like um also glitter to match
my elbow pads
it would be super low-cut to show off my
breastesses
the belts would be um rhinestones
glitter so no color belt just just
stones some glitter belts it would also
have a train like Oh gown oh yeah yeah
that's the most dysfunctional thing I've
ever heard
you would enter yourself and others and
probably be kicked out of your economy
but that sounds beautiful it would also
have a hood but a fashion know that
changes everything it would and it would
have footsies at the bottom okay you
just described like a onesie mm-hmm with
glitter and a tail that's what I think
you do when you go to Jude okay you know
and then I would rip it off and it would
be like that gif of that runway show
when he switches outfit yeah spooky
scary skeletons and then it would look
just like that on the inside yeah so
that get that vine is basically your
game yes all right and he is like a
glitter hat headband thing that's also
whatever as well okay well my question
for you is tell us what people think
jiu-jitsu is okay so I don't know what
the [ __ ] Josh my buddy Josh Evans was
doing today he's in Georgia and he was
snapchatting or Instagram story being
this like crazy karate party show
ceremony and it was probably a friend or
cousin or relative whatever of his who's
doing it but there there's literally
like a fire going there's a mat outside
there in the middle of the [ __ ] woods
the leader or the [ __ ] host has
sunglasses on with a mic while she's
wearing her full Gihon black belt of
course and they're running around kick
and [ __ ] punching [ __ ] fire sunglasses
in her hair down by the way goes over a
stack of it on fire runs over someone
throws her the mic she grabs the mic she
goes back to hosting and I'm just like
this is what my friends do this I mean
this is what my friends think I do when
I say I go to jujitsu
yeah every time I'm like I do no one
understands what it is no that's what my
friends think I do
just like stage to the gem and I kick it
like jiu-jitsu isn't that his lyric kick
back on that Glock call it jujitsu
there's no kickin ever ever ever in this
part of YouTube doesn't exist strike you
there's no like baby we kick it like
jiu-jitsu mm-hmm like why do people
think jujitsu involves kicking did they
do not one simple Google search no all
right
well this has been mild ones with mild
questions and even hotter wings and what
questions and statements sponsored by me
and these can we get that whole thing
engraved somewhere thank you guys for
hanging out with us hopefully you
enjoyed this special edition of the
janitors good honestly my favorite one
is Frank's redhot extra hot really yeah
by far I'm biased it's pretty damn good
I like I like the gringo Bandito cuz I
saw how deep it it burned you it was
good that was because you were like huh
I'm all cocky this ain't even hot hey
the whole thing that's what real heat is
it doesn't hit you right off the bat
I think that the Frank Frank's redhot
extra hot is like a really good it's
like a really nice amount of spicy yeah
just Frankfurt hot cannot do any wrong
knock you [ __ ] delicious cannot
anyway thank you guys for sticking with
us
I will see you guys not next week we'll
be at playlist there's gonna be no
podcast next week will be on twitch for
this week while we're in town get your
shirts while they're out thank you guys
for hanging out we love you see you next
one
[Music]
[Music]